you'll often hear the words depreciation
and amortization used together and what
I want to do in this video is to
understand a little bit better why they
are similar and the slight difference
between the two so in our previous
examples we've done depreciation and so
you can imagine in period 0 we buy a
truck for $60,000 and instead of just
expensing it in period zero instead of
putting $60,000 expense right over here
we capitalize it we say that we have a
$60,000 asset and so this is right at
the end of period zero or at the
beginning of period one and what we do
is we spread out this expense over the
period of time that we're actually going
to use the truck so in period one we
depreciate the truck by $20,000 we're
assuming we have a three year life of
this truck and we're just going to do
what's called straight-line depreciation
we're just going to take the cost of the
truck and divide it by its life there's
other ways to depreciate it maybe you
could imagine that it appreciates faster
in the first year but this is the
simplest type and it's actually used by
a lot of companies just straight
straight-line depreciation so after we
use $20,000 we depreciate the truck by
$20,000 we expense it in that year so
this is literally an expense then at the
end of period one it is now on our books
for $40,000 then in period two we
depreciate it by another $20,000 it is
going to be an expense a $20,000 expense
in period two now on our books at the
end of period two it'll be worth 20 then
period three we expense another $20,000
on our income statement and then on at
least four just this truck assuming we
haven't bought a new one yet we've
completely written it off it is now
worth zero on our books because it has
know just what based on what we assumed
it's not useful anymore we kind of have
to scrap this truck that's depreciation
now imagine if to run our trucking
business we also have to pay some type
of license fee so what does let me call
this a license a license fee and let's
say that the license fee was $4,000 and
we get to use it over four years so once
again you could have just put a $4,000
expense right over here but that doesn't
that's not really accurate you're not
just using the fee in that period that
fee is going to be useful over the next
four years so once again
you would put down the asset that you
know the paid license fee or maybe the
prepaid license fee depending on how you
view it and then you would amortize that
cost which is essentially the same thing
mathematically you'd say oh look I'm
going to use this over the next four
years essentially a thousand dollars a
year so my license fee amortization in
year one I'd say is one thousand dollars
and then on my books I would have
carried the license fee for three
thousand dollars
then I'd amortize another thousand
dollars then it'd go down to two
thousand dollars and were ties another
1000 dollars then at the end of period
three is now worth one thousand on my
books period for amortize another
thousand now I've completely written it
off and I probably have to get another
license at this point so mathematically
they're the same thing even
philosophically this they're the same
thing the idea that instead of expensing
these expenses all at once you're saying
look they have some useful life let me
spread out the expense over their useful
life the difference between the two and
you might have already kind of realized
this is depreciation is when you have
hard assets if you have a building or a
truck or some type of equipment that
would you would you would depreciate
that asset if you have a non hard asset
or a financial asset or something that's
less tangible then you would you would
just amortize it that's just the kind of
a different word depending on how
tangible the asset is so if it's a
license fee or some other type of fee or
some type of it may be intellectual
property you would amortize the cost if
you have a truck or a building or
whatever you would depreciate it